hello everyone and welcome to a really
spectacular game played in 1970 uh
tournament in islington london it's
terry c fox versus uh the legend jan the
man now we don't have all that uh much
info on tara c fox but we do know uh
that he played at least 12 games in his
entire life some of them are from
simultaneous exhibitions some of them
are from local events uh and we it seems
that he is an englishman but that seems
to be pretty much it and he's a fairly
strong player uh for example in 1972
this game was played in 1970 in 1972 he
defeated anatoly karpov in a
simultaneous exhibition albeit but still
i mean it's anatoly karpov
the man who uh yanti man challenged for
the title of world champion in 1993 so
definitely a strong player and this game
features a really awesome move that uh
well you sort of know about this move
but you never see it actually being
played and
you will
now understand why it's never played and
it is against the names of indian
defense which makes it even uh even more
awesome so let's dive straight into it
uh nine times dutch champion young demon
with the black pieces against the
mystery man terry c fox hence the uh
hoodie i hope you guys are wearing a
hoodie as well uh let's check it out uh
mr terry c fox opens with d4 yeah and
now knight to f6 uh going for the sort
of an indian type structure uh c4 e6
knight to c3 and timon goes for the
nimzo indian defense with bishop to b4
a3 challenging the bishop right away b
bishop captures on c3 and b character so
nowadays uh you know people don't really
enjoy doubling the c pawn but uh we've
seen it played even in in 2022 it still
can be used as a very nice surprise so
here's c5 challenging the center and now
there are this is the semi variation of
the names of indian here you want to
have the setup e3 f3 queen to c2
and so on but here we have a move that
you will never see anyone play against
you and that is pawn to e4 this is what
uh terry goes for and it's uh well okay
the the pawn obviously is not defended
but it's not a bad move because black
wants to capture the pawn if you capture
the pawn then queen g4 and all of a
sudden white has something here it's not
much but you know you can play at knight
f6 you capture the pawn rook here queen
h6 we we go after the queen let's see
queen to e3 and the game continues uh
but it's not really all that great but
the reason this is bad isn't because we
can capture the pawn the reason is uh
next and this this is what the t man
shows us queen to a5 now the threat is
queen captures in c3 this will come with
check but
our good friend terry fox says that this
is not a problem he doesn't defend the
pawn would sound like queen to d3 or
queen to c2 he just plays e5 and you can
see that he is a very very aggressive
attacker
knight to e4 and now
if you go for queen captures on c3 okay
bishop d2 and now white is definitely
winning black will have to give up a
piece so instead after e5 knights to e4
now timon goes after the c3 pawn uh with
the knight end with the queen and bishop
to d2
timon again does not go for some
material first he just continues
development knight to c6 and knight to
f3
knight captures on c3 now attacking the
terry's queen and d1 and queen to c2 and
here we have c captures on d4 just
cementing this knight
here on the on the c3 square and well
you you might think okay can't we just
capture this and then pick up the knight
here uh well not really because although
we can capture on d4 there's even queen
captures an e5 with check and now you
have all sorts of uh
problems for example you can block with
the knight knight captures an e2 and
what are you going to play i mean you
could recapture but the rook is hanging
on a1 so you you resign this so instead
after c captures on d4 a4 is played uh
and now comes pawn to b6 here timon
prepares to develop the bishop to a6 to
go after that c3 pawn so bishop to a c4
pawn so bishop to e2 now hoping the
castle but still you you don't really
have a chance of castling while uh the
uh the
uh bishop on e2 is hanging so here we
have bishop to a6 and now king to f1
obviously if we castle uh black can just
capture this comes with check so white
will not be in time to capture the black
queen so king the f1 leaving this
diagonal and now comes rook the c8 demon
just plays like a machine this game it
is absolutely incredible to watch
g3 preparing king to g2 of course terry
wants the castle artificially now and
now uh comes the uh the the big problem
for for terry knight captures an e5 and
what do you play here okay the knight is
defended so you don't really gain
anything by capturing the knight but you
can play knight captures on d4 and this
is exactly what terry plays this weakens
the knight on c3 but it's not a problem
that this is exactly what demon wanted
and he plays knight captures on e2 and
offers his queen and if you don't
capture the queen there's really not all
that much you can do you're just down
material let's say okay you can maybe
capture the the knight this way but then
we play queen d5 and again we offer a
queen for the second time now we're
attacking the pawn uh we're attacking
the rook on h1 and if the queen is
captured rook captures and c2 attacks
the bishop the bishop cannot move
because the knight hangs so it's just a
terrible position to to play so uh the
queen has to be captured uh queen bishop
captures an a5 was played and now we
have knight captures on d4 now preparing
to deliver some very nasty checks along
this diagonal uh queen to b2 as the
queen is also attacked the knight was
attacking the queen and now rook
captures on c for threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries once the rook moves
so kink the g2 and now bishop to b7 with
check and what do you do if you move the
if you go back with king to f1 we just
captured the rook it's a free rook uh if
you try something like
what can you even do here if you play
king the g1 to try and defend the rook
with the king then we play rook the c2
attack the queen and if queen captures
on d4 grabbing the knight then knight f3
check
again a nice fork winning the queen king
f1 knight captures here and we are up a
full piece of course we are winning this
game so after bishop to b7 czech king
the h3 saying okay if you capture my
rook i can recapture maybe i can survive
this but now comes knight the d3
attacking the queen here queen to d2
attacking the knight and now the
spectacular knight to f3 attacking the
queen and offering a knight here on d3
but the knight can't really be captured
if you capture the knight here then
knight to g5 is checkmate the bishop
covers the g2 square and the rook covers
of course the h4 and g for squares so
here uh terry said all right i can't
capture knight i'm just going to move my
queen he played queen to e3 but still
timon played knight to g5 with check and
he was in this position on move 21 that
terry c fox resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the problem is uh you don't have a
square for your king this is covered by
the bishop the the g4 and h4 squares are
covered by the rook and of course if the
knight is captured then you no longer
control the f2 pawn and that means that
if queen captures on g5 now knight
captures an f2 checkmate and that is
just just incredible again the bishop
covers this the real covers this the
knight delivers check this is uh i mean
amazing stuff
uh so uh that's basically it now you
know now you know why in this position
in the nimzo indian defense um
uh after this uh
sorry after this uh
c5 move no one plays e4 even though it
seems like it can be played because
knight captures an e4 is a bad move but
if someone plays this against you and
they might you know that queen to a5 is
a clear refutation of the idea you could
also play c characters on d4 but now
that you've seen this game you will go
for timon's idea play queen to a5 uh and
you know just crush your opponent uh uh
you know spectacularly
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for suggesting such
amazing games i
really enjoyed when i saw this one i'm
pretty sure i saw it like maybe 15 years
ago but um i have i have not seen it in
a very very very long time so hope you
guys really enjoyed this one only 21
move but uh spectacular nimzo indian
game uh so yeah once again i really hope
you enjoyed it i would like to thank
richard sanderson matteo georgia always
cluster harbor uh coleman d and val are
more ghoulish for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever how else happens in the
chess world uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day